what made you get into comedy you've
probably never been asked that before no
no I are you serious right now who are
some of your biggest influences okay W
Wanda Sykes okay okay you know I do
Wanda that was a good impression I
thought that was good good um I just
like make hearing people laugh okay and
and I like laughing a lot so Wanda Sykes
is your only influence no there's others
you already said Kyle written house but
I don't know about that never you said
he's a big influence on your Ben Shapiro
you said you like him a lot or you
listen to him every day Donald Trump
that you still refer to him as the
president mm you did say that earlier
you did say that earlier and you voted
for him and you voted for him even
before he ran you voted for him you just
wrote in you've been writing him in ever
since you could uh vote